Three two,
one.
Justin Wren,
ladies and gentlemen,
come on.
How low fella with the silky
hair and they're beautiful beard.
Oh,
thank you so much for having me.
My pleasure,
my brother.
How's things man?
Things are good.
Things are really good.
I mean,
last night you didn't go to the comedy
store for the first time and seeing all
those legends and just being
a legendary atmosphere.
I mean,
it was,
it was seriously an incredible time.
It's a fun place,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
and you had this role in a,
so it was,
it was really fun and got to see Brennan
and Brian Cowen first and then you,
and so it was just hilarious.
Did you get to go to the upstairs
room as well or did you add the two?
I was in the,
the belly room is upstairs.
Okay.
I'm Brandon and Brian
were in the main room.
I was there.
I was in the original room,
which that was an original.
Yeah.
So I didn't get to go to
the top two might tonight.
I'll show you the top.
It's a bizarre little place.
There's three comedy clubs in one place.
Yeah,
it was.
It was awesome.
Yeah,
it's fucking great.
Yeah.
Good.
Walking around,
seeing all the history,
seeing everyone get amped and then being
able to be that close to the comedians
too is pretty awesome.
I mean,
being able to meet him,
say hi and just,
uh,
you're,
you're an arm's distance from them.
So really unique.
If anyone hasn't gone,
I suggest going because it was awesome.
Yeah.
I think Chappelle is
filmed his Netflix special.
His next one he did
there in the belly room.
I watched him work one of them out.
I don't think he was filming then,
but I'm not sure.
Comes out soon.
Right.
Does it tick weirdly announced
that it comes out this month?
I think.
Whoa.
I'll double check on that real quick.
But I think so that might be
the case because it's so small.
There's probably not a lot of
camera angles and I know he'd deal,
he filmed a lot of shows,
so maybe he just wants to just get one
of them perfect and then throw it out.
But he had a lot of like
really topical material.
Real real current material was the,
was it smaller than the
room that you were in?
Lessening?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
We're not even half the size.
Wow.
Yeah.
See,
that's incredible.
December 31st that's crazy.
They don't have a video here,
but this is equanimity
is what it's called.
Nice.
It was funny,
man.
He's,
he's,
it was really funny and it,
and seeing him in that tiny little room,
like there was 70 people in the room.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
They did get more in there sometimes,
but don't tell the fire department
fucking shouldn't speak in the fire
department.
Oh Man.
It's crazy out here,
huh?
Yeah.
I mean,
I seen that video posts on your Instagram.
It's seriously looks like Armageddon.
Yeah.
That's from bar to bar stool sports.
If anybody wants to go
to their Instagram page,
they,
somebody put up a video of a last
night driving up the four oh five gosh.
It's the craziest thing.
You don't ever say it's
an entire mountain.
What's crazy is that's bel air.
I mean,
that's like a really ritzy area.
Super expensive houses,
and that fire is just raging towards them.
It's right near the Getty center.
And what apparently with their calling,
this is a dry hurricane.
Wow.
So I don't live in California
and I'm not a homeowner yet.
But does home owner insurance cover all
that or do you have to have extra lake
fire insurance is a very good
question and I don't know the answer.
Yeah,
cause my,
my family was in Hurricane
Katrina and because they,
they had hurricane insurance but
they didn't have like wind insurance.
And so why insurance companies and say
or flooding insurance or something like
that.
It was whatever you didn't have,
you would get one and not the other.
And so then whatever you didn't have,
that's what the insurance
company would claim.
Well you didn't have this and that's what
you should have had or losing tons of
money.
Their homes,
whole homes.
My family lost a whole
roof off their house.
Ah,
these monsters.
Yeah.
And so that's what I'm wondering.
Like you,
okay,
you have a homeowner insurance,
but do you have fire insurance
and are they going to cover that?
You know,
if those are,
if that's bel air and that's
build million dollar homes,
hopefully they have the right insurance.
I'm sure some people have fire insurance.
I know it's a thing,
just like hurricane and flood
insurance is also a thing,
but do have fire hurricane,
it's a good question.
Well,
yeah,
right.
This is a fire arcane.
It's not just a hurricane.
Well,
it's a,
they're calling it a dry hurricane
mean there's dryer or there's no water,
but it's,
it's hurricane gale force winds,
gale force.
I don't know if that's right.
Hurricane force winds.
It's technically not like,
you know,
in my hotel.
I mean,
wind was just ripping all last night and
they know that there's those fires out
there.
I mean,
that's crazy.
Yeah,
it's insane,
man.
Um,
I,
where I live,
I was evacuated twice.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
Twice in the early two thousands
where the fire got so close.
It was within a mile of my house.
And you know,
when it hits in,
the wind goes,
it can take over.
Like it can just run.
They said that the fires that they
were having in northern California,
we're going through an entire
football field every six seconds.
Gosh,
that,
that's mind blowing.
Fuck man.
Just imagine watching that,
watching fires just cut
through a football field,
hundred yards every six seconds.
It's almost like those clouds
and the storms are rolling.
Yeah.
You're just watching those go by.
A lot of people died in those
northern California fires too.
They just got stuck.
There's nowhere to get out.
And they apparently like
that whole Napa area is,
have you ever been up there?
No Yam before the fires.
I don't know what it looks like right now,
but it kind of is beautiful.
It's where they do all the wine making,
you know?
And um,
we actually,
uh,
went Turkey hunting up there.
Me and Brian Cowen.
Oh Nice.
Yeah.
Steve Rinella took us up there and
we were up there and we were like,
God,
this is so gorgeous.
But it's like semi rural,
but then a big tourist
vacation destination too.
It's like people come there for those
wine tasting things and everything.
Apparently a giant chunk of that
part of the state just got lit up.
And when you,
when you go Turkey hunting,
are you using a boat?
Are you using this shotgun shot guns?
This was for the media to show.
So do you have to like go for their,
their head,
right?
Yeah.
That's nuts.
So cause you can't get their
body or it goes everywhere,
right?
Well then you have to
pull out all the led,
you know,
which you like when people shoot smaller
birds like pheasants and things along
those lines.
You do shoot the entire body.
But with the Turkey you basically sitting
still and you call a menu bar and make
this little,
they get this little sound thing in your
hand or you have one in your mouth and
you make little Turkey calls and the
turkeys come in and just blast him in the
head or,
or you shoot him in the body,
uh,
with a bow.
Um,
I know,
uh,
my friend John Dudley
and lot of those guys,
they hunt with bows and they've,
they shoot turkeys for the bow.
But it's tricky because the
Turkey's a goddamn dinosaur.
And if you don't hit it in the right spot,
they'll just fly away with an
Arrow sticking out of them.
Like literally.
Well,
something that kills a deer go right
through a Turkey and the Turkey.
He's like,
I'm Outta here.
Like you have to catch
them and their vitals,
their vitals are,
you literally are shooting an
Arrow at a soft ball from you know,
40 yards.
Yeah.
Well may have seen this
new space is awesome.
I mean this is incredible new studio and
seeing that your targets are up there
yet.
Got What?
48 40 47 yards.
70 yards indoors.
Yeah,
but when you come back,
man,
we'll have a full gym.
You'll be able to work
out and the whole deal.
Yeah,
no,
that's awesome dude.
After you watch the UFC and
you saw Frances and gone,
oh did you see if you could make two
oh five that's a lot of people don't.
A lot of people are like,
I could make,
I could make to a five.
I think it's totally possible.
I've always been against it,
but now I'm thinking about it.
Just getting by.
He,
man,
he's,
he is a monster.
It's terrifying monster to see
how far he sent the Overeem.
Sad.
It was just backwards in that one photo.
That's like an iconic,
that's probably the most iconic,
at least in my mind.
Um,
or epic heavyweight
fighting MMA fighting photo,
um,
that there is,
I mean with the thing,
so to knock back that way and I mean
it just looks like such a power.
I mean it was a powerful punch,
but the timing of that
shot was just incredible.
You see that one where his head
is just really knocked back man.
Scary.
Scary dude.
I put that one on my
Instagram feed to that.
That picture seems like
the coming of the new king,
you know what I mean?
Like obviously he's got to
beat Steve Bay Meo Chick,
but if you want to like look at a picture,
like in history when you come back and go,
this is the moment where in Ghana
arrived and people realize like,
Holy Shit,
like this guy is for real.
He didn't just do that to any guy.
He did that to Allister
motherfucking over.
Yeah.
K One kickboxing world champion.
Strikeforce world champion.
Just a stud.
But like elite fighter.
Yeah.
Number one heavyweight contender.
Well you,
you and Brendan were talking
about it last week on the show.
And to hear you guys saying if
he starches him and if he can,
if he can prove himself in,
it's like,
man,
he just did it the best way possible.
And the way he did it,
it's like the whole world's noticing,
like I saw it on CNN,
I saw it on all these different
websites and they're just,
everyone's just raving like he
could be the next big thing.
And I think that's going to put them
on the map now that everybody knows and
they have this highlight
reel of his knockouts now.
Yeah.
And so the,
the advertise a fight
between him and Steve Bay,
I think it's going to be gigantic.
Yeah.
I think it's gonna be huge.
Uh,
I've been able to talk with Steve based
coach and there's a potential I was
going to go out and help them,
uh,
in this training camp.
So hopefully that still happens.
My schedule is kind of crazy,
but hopefully I can get up there
for a week or sneak up there.
Um,
I'm,
I'm happy for steep bed.
He'd get a big fight.
Yeah,
for sure.
And if he wins against in Ghana,
I mean,
that is just gigantic.
Yeah,
that would be absolutely phenomenal.
There's a guy that can do it.
Steve Bay for sure.
Well,
he's the champ and he's
a champ for a reason,
but he's got a lot of work to do.
He's so big.
Got to weather that storm it put them
up against the cage where I'm out.
Pomo.
I mean,
just,
just get really heavy on
them and a tire amount.
Dan,
a deep waters put them on his back.
We've got to remember Overeem
did get him up against the cage.
Yeah,
that's true.
Dream lunged at,
I'm clenched with him.
Got Him up against the but couldn't
do a God damn thing with them.
That's true.
I think a little differences.
A steep way.
Having that all American wrestling
background when they're a little bit more
crazy.
He's opening up as the betting
favorite over the heavyweight champion.
Steep Emile chick.
I mean,
this is an amazing,
I get it,
I understand,
but that is pretty incredible
that he's the betting favorite.
I guess if we just look at his
comment that do MMA math or so,
but,
uh,
the,
the common opponent with the Elman over
him and you know how they both performed
against him?
Yeah,
well Overeem did catch the bay and had
him stunned and knocked him on his house
and then Steve Bay came back and won.
But you know,
he's going to be obviously super aware
of how dangerous it is to connect with in
Ghana and he's going to obviously
try to stay on the outside and uh,
when he closes the distance,
close distance,
get that clinch,
get him up against the cage and figure
out some way to either get that guy down
or where his legs out or do something.
We don't know what happens when
in Ghana goes into the third,
fourth,
and fifth rounds.
Right.
If anybody can even
physically take him there.
Yeah,
I do love how steep it has that killer
instinct both against over him after
getting hurt.
Uh,
even for doom after his leg injury,
but then they'll,
yeah.
Oh,
sorry.
Yeah,
you're right.
The dos Anjos fight.
Yeah.
He's till Santos had kicked his leg
pretty hard and giant swelling on his leg.
Yeah.
Then to come back and just knock them out.
The way that he did was just beautiful.
Yeah.
This is,
even if he gets hurt,
if he doesn't get put out and he's hurt,
he can still,
you can still turn on that killer
instinct and put them away.
So yeah,
it's going to be exciting.
Like watching this fight,
I'm amped for it.
This is one of the big heavyweight fights
recently that I'm just so stoked for.
Yeah.
That's the big one.
I think it's probably the
biggest heavyweight fight ever.
When you think about what and gone,
who is,
you know,
I mean,
there's obviously been some giant fights
like Brock Lesnar when he fought Cain
Velasquez.
Barack was there when he fought over him.
Those were huge fights.
But I think that in Ghana knew something
special and if Steve Bay could figure
out how to turn him down,
how to shut him down and beat him.
I mean it will really cement his position
as the baddest man on the planet.
And if not,
we got a new king.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's really,
I was even thinking
when you're saying those last fights,
uh,
this one I'm as excited for,
whereas whenever Brock fought chink,
Carwyn helping me and Brendan both were
helping chain train for that fight and
now I might be involved for a week or so.
I'm helping Steve Bay
get ready for this one.
Just being around that scene,
the preparations,
what they're going to do.
Um,
even just being a training partner for
that legendary fight would be pretty
epic.
Are you going to shave lightening
bolts in your head to emulate in Ghana?
Um,
I,
I'm at least going to die black
lightening bolts in my hair.
Just be the reverse.
The Vanilla Gorilla version that'd
be trained to Steve Bay before.
I haven't,
I haven't just talked
to his coach is a bit,
so they thought it'd be a great
idea and I think it is too.
So He's out there in Cleveland,
I'm sure.
I mean,
he's got some incredible team around him.
And you're in Oklahoma City
now in Oklahoma City with,
yeah.
That's awesome.
And he's killing it out there.
Oh my gosh.
It,
well he's undefeated seven
to know strangling people.
Gosh,
and knocking people out too,
which is crazy.
He started boxing or at least a
kickboxing before he ever started Jujitsu.
So as a kid is his father and him,
I don't know if you know what they're
the first ever American father,
son,
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belts and um,
man,
but they have this background
of just everything.
That's awesome.
Since like early nineties
just go in and cross training.
He's from that old school.
Like he goes like Hixon Gracie solid,
he barrow,
Shawn g and then you know,
he's in that group of those,
that style of Jitsu.
Jujitsu is just smush style.
Those guys have just
tremendous pressure basics.
And when I say basics,
I mean like the hard polished tried
and true techniques and it's like,
there's not like a lot of fancy,
crazy new school stuff,
but it's just laser sharp and just
smashing hour and the pressure,
such a big fan of like he's always talking
about the pressure passing and just
melting into,
into him being a wet hot
blanket on top of them.
Just taking their airway,
making them give up.
And Man,
honestly,
I've trained with guys like Carwyn and
mirror and couture and Overeem and I've
trained with some of the biggest heavy
weights around and he is the only person
and he fights at want 85.
He's the biggest one.
He five or I've ever seen,
I can't imagine that,
uh,
I don't know how he makes that cut,
but he does it.
So,
uh,
in such incredible ways that the
healthiest guy I've ever met,
most disciplined Athlete
d most disciplined person
I've ever been around in my
entire life,
obsessed with discipline and training,
the,
the performance mindset
or competitive mindset,
the guys,
the the best I've ever been around.
But he is the only person to ever make
me completely claustrophobic underneath.
I've never been claustrophobic
underneath anyone and he just takes my,
not in a weird way,
but he takes my breath away and yeah,
but I mean just,
he,
he makes you want to quit.
He,
he and he's so,
and he's always about putting yourself
in the worst position possible and
becoming uncomfortable
or being comfortable,
being uncomfortable and just making
yourself to where no matter where you get
Putt,
like you're going to find out of it,
you're always just one
step away from a finish.
Like you finishing them.
Even if they are about to finish you,
you're,
you're just,
you're just a few small steps,
just inches away from
getting out of there,
reversing it,
taking their back,
you know,
putting them on their back and
mounting and just finishing and,
and he's,
he's incredible.
He's the only guy that I've ever seen
be able to go through like 10 10 minute
rounds or sorry,
ten eight minute rounds back to back
when he was training for the ADCCs.
Why,
I mean he's just an animal and no,
10,
tens,
it was 10 tens and I was just
blown away that he could do that.
And we were having to
rotate fresh guys on them.
And by the end of it,
he got tired of it.
But that was the only time I've ever
seen him tired but actually tired.
And so he's just an absolute animal.
It's a lifestyle for him.
It's honestly so incredibly inspiring.
And I feel like just being around them
and me doing a lot of the same things
that that's what's going to make
me the Bellator heavyweight champ.
But like just us feeding off each other.
It's really cool dynamic.
But if I can be half as
disciplined as he is,
I'll be the most disciplined
heavyweight fighter there is.
Um,
so it's,
it's,
it's pretty amazing being around him
and his mindset and how he travels the
world,
seeking out the,
um,
the top instructors in every discipline.
I mean,
he's going down to Brazil to,
um,
evil,
Osa,
tie,
a bow tie.
Um,
that used to be,
it's kind of like intro to box,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
It used to be shooting boxing
and he goes in Cartiva,
right?
Yup.
Curitiba and goes and soaks up those good
vibes at the largest waterfall in the
world or one of them.
And then it's just in training camp
as these guys Portuguese he does,
he got a lot of people
mistake home as Brazilian,
but his family Spanish and he grew up in
Oklahoma City so there's not resilient
and nobody speaks fluent
Portuguese to learn.
Uh,
I think through Jujitsu,
Jujitsu,
being around people always trying
to put himself in those situations.
And then he would go down,
I think it was a 16 year old kid
and he would go down to Brazil,
sometimes by himself and stay for like
a month or two or think you might have
done it a foot for four
months at one time.
Wow.
Um,
so he's a really,
really special individual.
He's the guy that I've,
I've never seen take,
take a break or take off.
I mean he competed,
he fought three times and Bella this year,
three,
no,
I'm in between that.
He had a super fight with blue Chechnya.
He had another grappling tournament.
He had the ADCCs you're just
going from every two months.
He was competing every two months,
but he was staying healthy
the whole time too,
which blew my mind because he takes us,
we have a place called the arc that we
train the athlete recovery center and
it's got hot and cold plunges and infrared
saunas in the cryotherapy and the uh,
just all sorts of stuff.
Those NormaTec boots and our pts there
and our strength conditioning coaches
right there.
So it's all in one shop.
And so right after he's done training,
he's recovering where he gets there
early and he's stretching out.
And so the whole warming up truly and
cooling down and taking care of your body
and putting the right fuel in it,
eating whole foods at all times,
like just not putting
garbage in your body,
man.
He's going to be,
uh,
the Bella tour,
a middle weight champion.
Um,
probably pretty soon.
I think they have that maybe lined
up in the next two or three fights.
I'm excited.
I'm excited to see him compete against
like really upper echelon guys.
Like guys like new
saucy along those lines.
Yeah.
The guy who just fought.
Um,
Chris Hani cut was in the NCAA finals.
That was the first high level
wrestler these competed against.
He won every single round.
Um,
the first six fights,
he finished everybody.
Um,
and so it's going to be exciting if,
if,
if there's someone
watching this that hasn't,
you know,
watched Rafael Lovato junior compete,
whether it's in grappling or MMA,
like go follow him because he's,
he's going to do it and
he's going to be a champ.
Yeah,
he's a savage for sure.
What does he weigh before he makes the
cut 25 so I don't want to put a specific
number,
but I think it's around
two 10 to 15 to 20,
something like that.
Um,
so I know whenever he's in camp he's
trying to walk around at a less than 200
when he can.
And he's about like what,
six to now?
He's six,
four,
six,
four and he's kind of like
some of the longest reach.
Yeah,
he's at least in 25.
That's crazy.
I think it's probably a
size 1314 is Instagram.
And you could see a picture
of him with his shirt off.
Homeboy is fucking shredded red man.
He's,
he's,
he's gotta be in the neighborhood
of like eight or 9% body fat.
Yeah.
Zero.
But there's just shredded,
just as a heavyweight.
I've always just envied anyone
that was under 15 or whatever.
So I mean,
come on son.
Yeah,
sure.
Shredded.
And,
uh,
and he looks down at every,
every,
every guy has ever fought.
I mean,
if you see other way in photos,
like they're all looking up at him,
like literally their chins up in the
shore and he went through a pretty
significant injury a few years back.
Right.
Didn't you have like a peck tears?
Yeah,
I think it was the,
is there a peck tendon
or something like that?
I think was the tendon in there that
connects like the shoulder and the Pec and
completely tore it and had
to have reconstructive,
uh,
surgery.
And Man,
the guy's so discipline.
I mean,
he went through like anyone,
all of us athletes would,
um,
being bummed out a bit.
But,
uh,
you know,
he had this machine that was,
moving his arm up and down and,
you know,
just sitting there.
Um,
but then the guy is a planner,
a visualizer.
Like he takes advantage even
the times he's not on the mat.
He's structuring his life around it,
towards writing down his
goals and his dreams.
And this month's plan,
the next three months plan,
uh,
this week's plan,
this day's plan.
I'm just writing every single thing out
so that way he can make sure that he's
doing everything.
Can't even when he's not training,
he's,
he's training,
you know,
he's trained his mind,
he's training a everything
for that so that he can,
he can perform at the best.
And I think that's why he
competes at such a high level.
And I'm,
I'm speaking about him like this,
but it's all true.
It's all honest.
I'm not just trying to give the guy props,
like he earned that from me at least.
And I think you should from pretty
much anyone who competes with because
um,
man,
I mean his match with boot Chacha even
was so competitive and could have easily
won that match.
I mean,
he could warm the ADCCs.
easily he attaches a big fellow too.
Yeah,
I know.
Like two,
two 45 of just hike just
and then worldclass.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I mean one the ADC.
I think for now a big Lavato Fan,
I think he's awesome.
Yeah,
I'm excited to see,
I always love when the really the highest
level guys in any discipline enter
into MMA,
you know?
And when you see a guy like cam was just,
uh,
just ginger Jujitsu
phenom and now he's like,
okay,
now I'm going to try to take over MMA or
a guy like go con Saki enters into the
UFC.
Like,
oh,
okay,
let's see what happens when you get like
a real high level guy in any discipline
who enters into MMA.
It's always interesting because
there's such specialists,
because most MMA fighters,
you know,
pretty good at wrestling,
pretty good at Jujitsu,
pretty good at kickboxing,
but not elite like world class world
championship level at any different
discipline.
So when you see a guy who is like Rafael
Lovato is world class that you just see
like world championship level
and then enters into MMA,
it's like,
Ooh,
what you're going to do.
And he grabbed you.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Like daily in my world who
Rafael is and seeing or for doom.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
And something special about
Raphael again and then,
but anyways,
he's a,
he can coach it so incredibly well too.
And that's not always the
case with a lot of athletes.
I've been coached by a lot
of incredible wrestlers.
Um,
Kenny Monday,
Kendall Cross,
they were incredible coaches.
Cael Sanderson.
Um,
I've been coached on the maths
by Dan Gable and some other guys.
Um,
so absolute legends and his coaching
is also just so thorough and so exact.
And it's,
it's like you see the guy
at the top right now who's,
who's performing at the best and he's
able to teach it at such a high level that
that's why he's,
you know,
coached up some other grappling
world champions and stuff like that.
And it's focuses on MMA.
He's just perfect timing the him and I
got to train together for a full year now
and taking it in 2018
both of us want to be,
you know,
hunting down those belts.
Did you move down to Oklahoma City
specifically to train with him?
There was a few reasons.
Um,
but yeah,
that was,
that was one of the big ones I was going
to regardless because water is based
out of there and fight for the
forgotten is underneath water for.
And so we're,
we're partners with him,
um,
and they've taken over all
the administrative stuff
and we're officially an
initiative underwater for,
it's nice.
Yeah.
I mean it's the,
it's,
it's incredible.
Um,
so,
so stoked that they're,
they're making things just flourish.
We're going to serve over 200,000
people with clean water this year.
That's so incredible.
And we're doing a benefit tonight at
the comedy store and it's going to be
incredible.
The prompt one of many.
I think we're going to start
doing these all the time there.
I just think,
and we do shows there all the time and
most of the time we just do shows and I'm
like,
well,
why shouldn't we just do shows?
And like couple times a month or so,
just donate all the money.
So that's what we're going to do,
man.
I'm blown away by it.
So stoked.
Um,
well I found out right before
we got on the podcast that there's a
generous donor out of Oklahoma City.
Um,
and he's going to match whatever comes in,
uh,
today,
on the website,
whether that's at the comedy
store now I'm up to $10,000.
So the first $10,000 will be matched.
And so that first 10,000 will be doubled,
will turn into 20,000.
Um,
so just so stoked.
So whatever comes in through the doors,
uh,
man,
it can be doubled it.
That's beautiful,
man.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
like a first time we did this,
we got bitcoin from people
and they donated bitcoin.
And I have that bitcoin on my phone
and I have to get it off the phone.
But that big coin is now worth like
$50,000 so what I did was I took that
Bitcoin,
I took the cash version of it and I
don't need to water four and then I'm Mac
matched it and now we're up to,
so all that additional money is yours too.
Like it's not mine,
it's yours.
So it's like there's an
additional $45,000 in there.
Yeah.
So we got to get it off,
get it off the phone,
but that'll go to waterfall as well.
Man,
I can't,
this isn't fake.
I can't pick this kind of smell.
Awesome man.
Yeah.
And it's,
the thing is that was trade in there for
a while because if you keep it in there
with for a while might be worth even more.
Do you bail now?
What do you
it might go way up.
Oh well then we can keep blaming.
Wait,
wait up.
Like how way?
Like speculation in the next six to 12
months is at least 20,000 if not 50,000.
Whoa.
That's like way high speculation.
I'm not,
oh my God.
Oh that's what I'll do.
I'll leave it up to you guys.
We'll get the
bitcoin off the phone and
then I'll essentially leave
it up to you guys when you
want to pull the trigger and
take the money out of it.
Okay.
Because that seems to be the right cause.
Like,
well let's,
let's first I thought advisors to tell us,
you know what,
I'm going to get Andrea's Antonopoulos,
he's going to be on the podcast soon
and he's the guy who set up all this big
coin stuff for me in the first place.
Um,
the big coins all came in as donations.
So just so everybody knows,
like,
cause some people accused me of
not donating that money to you.
And I had explained to them,
no,
I took the big coin and I just,
whatever the money value of it was,
then I gave that to you guys.
So,
but I remember that.
But the,
what's left,
I still,
it's not mine.
It's,
it's,
you know,
just because I gave,
I mean I have it,
but it's not mine.
It's yours.
So it's all donation.
That's just,
I thought as a science project,
I'm like,
let's just see what
happens when they shit,
I don't want to take it out.
It could have been zero,
worthless.
Want to turn it into money.
I didn't want to cash it out.
So I said,
let me just give you guys whatever
money it is and I'll hold on to that and
they'll see what happens with it.
But now it's worth 50 grand.
Wow.
That's nuts.
So yeah,
more than that.
Six 65 oh Jesus.
Yeah.
It keeps going up.
It's quick on a crazy spike right now.
Wow.
That was worth $13,000 holy shit.
Whoa,
that's,
that's crazy.
And I will also put out my bitcoin address
once I get it off the phone for you
guys,
if you want to
donate money,
and again,
all of that money,
none of it goes to me.
It's all going to go to water.
Four it's all going to go
to fight for the forgotten,
which is the shirt that I'm wearing and
that's what the benefit is tonight at
the comedy store.
All the money is going to fight for the
forgotten and you can donate to at what
is the website,
right.
Fight for the forgotten.org/donate and
if you guys haven't paid attention any
Justin's podcasts before,
I'll give you a brief run down.
Justin was on the ultimate fighter,
fought for the UFC for a while and then
found his true calling going to the
Congo and building wells for the
pygmies and it's just an amazing story.
You could watch some of the podcasts,
you can watch some of the short clips on
you and I know there's a documentary on
you that's coming out soon as well.
Yeah,
I think he's going to be the summer of uh,
2018 and so thank you so much for even
doing a sit down interview on that.
And my pleasure,
my pleasure.
And had a whole lot of
value to the film and,
and just give it a louder voice or a wider
reach because my first promise to the
pygmies,
and this was even,
um,
so man,
I'm just so thankful for the support
of this community and personally you,
uh,
because man,
when I first came on,
we haven't drilled any wells.
In fact,
I had just had Andy,
um,
you know,
I had held him and he's an old and a half
year old boy that I held has he passed
away and uh,
and it wrecked me.
It changed me and it,
but I knew we were going
to do something with water.
I just knew it.
Um,
but my first time on the podcast
there were zero wells drilled.
I was just going to go there and live
for a year and hopefully we were going to
build an incredible team.
That team is now 20 strong,
a fulltime,
12 part time,
um,
been able to drill 70 water wells now.
It's amazing.
70 communities have been transformed.
Um,
if that bitcoin is 50 grand,
I mean 4,265 he said,
oh my gosh,
well,
I'm not a math whiz.
So,
uh,
I,
if I,
if we're living,
but um,
but it's a $4,200 transforms a community.
Uh,
it helps our teams go out
there and survey the land.
We have a survey team now that gets
to go out and scout it out beforehand.
Um,
tell our teams what tools to bring
out and what obstacles to expect.
Um,
so that's a few hundred
dollars for $500 to go survey.
Um,
then to drill the wells around $2,700,
and then to help the community
and really teach and train them.
So we educate the locals with the
knowledge on how to drill the wells.
We equip them with the
tools to be able to do it.
Um,
how many of them can read?
So a,
of our well drillers,
everyone,
well,
I think everyone can,
a lot of them have even
graduated from a University of,
uh,
with community development degrees.
Uh,
I mean the people that
live in the community,
pygmies,
the Mu boothy pygmies,
none of them.
I've met two people,
I think two,
maybe three that can
actually read a in there,
the chiefs.
Um,
one of them is actually an incredible guy,
chief Alondo grandsons,
Jimmy,
and he's going to be chief one day.
That's like my favorite
little guy over there.
Um,
and Gypsy's in school now.
And,
uh,
there's a long story with that,
but it's,
it's one of the first
times ever them a booty.
Pygmies I've ever been in school,
uh,
and sustainably to where they can even
pay their school fees and they can have
food there because they can buy the food.
Um,
and so,
but traditionally they don't
have a written language.
Um,
they don't have a calendar,
so they don't know their age.
Um,
and so they're really,
really traditional
hunter gatherer society.
That's just a incredible,
you'd love them there.
You know,
with the Bose,
they're,
they're deadly.
I've seen a little boy,
uh,
probably eight,
nine,
10 years old.
Um,
climb up.
Uh,
the canopy of the rain forest is probably,
it's well over a hundred feet.
It's probably 150,
200 feet.
Um,
and senior guys shimmy up there,
eight,
nine,
10 years old to the top and a,
it was a guy with a bow on
is like hung around his neck.
Um,
and so he goes up there
and then he's sniping,
you know,
parents or,
or other kinds of birds,
parrots,
anything they can find,
man.
So I,
one thing that they do,
I don't know why this popped in my mind,
but uh,
if they're running in their hunting
after an antelope a and a bee flies by,
they're going to chase that
bead to the hive because,
uh,
they,
they honey to them was like gold.
I mean it's,
it's,
they love honey having something sweet.
So they'll risk their lives
to climb up into the trees.
They set a fire at the bottom of the tree,
let the smoke go up,
and then they climb up there
and they just reach in.
And these are African beads,
these are killer bees that
they're reaching into the
honey hive and just pulling
it out and dropping it down in a basket.
We're just,
we're just plopping it down.
Just can't leave
sometimes too.
People go up there and the one guy's
purpose is just to have like a,
a twig and leaves that he's hitting the,
the bees off of the
guy reaching in cheese.
So he's just protecting them.
But then when those guys come back into
the village and they have this just
treasure pot of,
of,
of honey,
the whole village celebrates their heroes.
Um,
and you know,
cause they literally did risk
their lives for their wives,
for the kids so that they
could have some honey.
Wow.
Then they save it,
they savor it.
Uh,
and it's,
it's,
it's pretty incredible.
Another other thing they do is if
they're on a hunt and they find a turtle,
um,
they'll actually make,
it looks almost like the kids here
that have like Ninja turtle backpack.
They'll tie a vine around the feet of
the turtle and then they put it on their
back and then they go back to hunting.
And if they get an animal,
if they get like no,
they just keep it alive
and it's on their back.
And if they get a kill of an antelope
or a wild hog or something like that,
they actually left the turtle go.
And then if they,
yeah,
they,
they only take what they need.
So they respect the
forest and its resources.
Um,
so much so they only keep what they need.
Fucking tumultuous ride
for that poor turtle.
Yeah,
you're right about that.
All the fuckers find a peg,
but,
but if they,
if they don't and they have food and
dinner later for their kids and so they
bring it back and they'll just cut
it open and put it on the fire and,
uh,
and have eaten turtle there.
Um,
it's not the best.
It's,
it's a,
it's really gave me,
and um,
uh,
it really,
really chewy the kind that I had.
And
I don't know what part I had,
but I've,
I've had even monkey there.
Uh,
th this was before I was there during
the Ebola breakout and everything.
Um,
but,
uh,
I didn't know that you get it from
eating monkey and so they just,
they eat monkey all the time.
I've been in monkey several times now,
probably it probably five,
six,
seven times.
Wow.
It's going to sound goofy,
but it's super Tinder.
Um,
it was some of the best meat I've had.
The one they gave me,
I think it was part of like the,
around the femur bone or whatever.
Does it freak you out to you to prime it?
Uh,
it didn't know at first I thought it was
kind of crazy and then after I tasted
it,
it was really,
really good.
And so after that,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's good.
My friend Steve Rinella went to,
um,
where was it in South
America that he went to?
I cannot remember,
but he was a down there hunting with
this tribe and they prefer monkey over
everything.
Oh Man.
It's that good.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's why it's good.
Really good.
I'm not just saying that,
I mean it's,
it's really good.
And they celebrate whenever,
whatever one Keysight as they bring back,
whether it's a big one or a little guy,
they're gonna,
they're gonna really celebrate
because that's some of the,
they call it the sweet meat.
So say he's at,
yeah,
they're eating monkey still.
Does it say where he's at?
Olivia.
Bolivia.
That's it.
Yeah.
That's a,
I think there's even a youtube video
sometimes people can go check out on my
youtube channel of me,
try and monkey for the first time.
I thought they were teasing me.
And so at the end I know it's,
this is chicken,
it's gotta be chicken.
And they're like,
no,
it's monkey.
And after I got off,
they walked me outside to,
to where the monkey like carcass
was still there and everything.
And I was like,
Dang,
this is real.
Like it's really,
really,
really good.
And I said,
it tastes like chicken.
Yeah.
That's funny cause Rinella said it
tasted like a smoked Turkey leg.
Yeah.
So like the way they go,
they cooked it over like
the meat consistent use,
uh,
over the fire.
Yeah.
It's just
some man.
It's awesome.
And we're about to get two
to 3000 more acres of land.
No.
Yeah,
my kids coming in.
I hope so.
But no,
I don't think I'd be a hunter
if that was all he could hunt.
It was monk said,
I'd be like,
I think I'm going Vegan.
He's a vegetarian coming back here.
You know my wife like shed a tear
I think because I ate a monkey.
Yeah.
I mean I think she was,
she was like,
wait a what?
So I think she still thinks I just
had one instead of five or six.
One hour should know.
Yeah,
actually.
she does know because of this.
But um,
man,
it's,
it's such an adventure living out there.
And so to be able to empower the locals
to do it for themselves is just so key.
Like that's,
that's,
I guess the message I'm
preaching is just the,
is greater than charity.
That's why I asked you if they could read,
if it's like,
do they,
do you give them instruction manuals,
how to maintain and how to,
the upkeep for wells or
how to build a new one or,
so with the pygmies,
they're involved in helping
us get our equipment
out there.
I mean,
sometimes our hikes are from
the nearest quote unquote road,
which none of us would call a road at all.
And the same drive.
Some of the times the drive to
the beginning of the rain forest,
we're from the airport
is four no six hours.
The same exact drive has
taken 24 hours or 48 hours.
We had to dig out like 40 cars in front
of us one time because they were just
stuck in the mud.
Um,
and to get around it.
So,
but once we get to the rain forest,
that can take an hour,
two hours,
three hours to hike each way.
Um,
and so a round trip to with one ton of,
well drilling equipment is a lot
to the whole village helps us.
I mean,
there's a incredible Swahili
proverb that basically says,
if you think you are,
if you want to go fast,
go alone,
but if you want to go far,
go together.
And so I think it's
beautiful because they,
they don't even let us
do all the work alone.
They know that there were going to
come come in there and help them with
something that's so precious.
That's life saving,
life giving to them.
So,
uh,
they,
they all send a hundred people to
come help us with our equipment.
And so what,
what used to take us days to take in,
you know,
it takes us just that one trip and
so they help us get it in there.
They build us huts.
So basically they build us a
home just like what they live in.
Um,
very hospitable.
Give us our food while we're there.
If Dan was so happy that you showed up,
you imagine some big white dude
from America out of nowhere.
It's just like,
Hey,
I'm going to live with
you guys and make well.
They'd be like,
yeah,
sure you are.
Nobody didn't come down here and
made a well to fuck outta here.
Yeah,
mean you made 70 wells.
Now they must be like,
how is this possible?
Yeah,
well,
well what I love is the,
the heroes of this are
our 32 well drillers.
We even have now you have to share on
your podcasts last time that Pacha soap,
which was inspired by this podcast and
listening to this working at night,
the night shift and having
a dream to start Pacha soap,
which is in whole foods and they got
another brand that's in target is super
successful and it's awesome.
Yeah.
They're helping us buy land.
They're in the Congo and we're still
starting up a soap production facility,
so we have an essential oil press and
we're hiring the locals to be able to get
all this central oils that you can flip
this and avocado oil and palm oil and
different raw materials because the only
thing they have available to him right
now,
his car washing soap,
that's literally from China or from India.
It's just packed with chemicals.
Right.
When I use it,
let me raw.
I mean like in pain from it
and so off with no soap at all.
Just wash yourself with dirt.
Right.
And so you can do that
if people don't know,
if you just take dirt,
like if you're somewhere
and there's no no soap,
just take dirt and just literally use
water and mud and just wash yourself with
the dirt and then rinse it all off.
You just trying to scrub
off the bullshit and dirt.
It's probably better for
you than antibiotic soaps.
Yeah,
for sure.
And so we're about to get two
to 3000 acres more of Lance.
We have 3000 there,
NASA man.
And it's about to be five to 6,000 acres.
If we reach out and reach out to people,
cause I know a lot of people do like
to go to places like that and teach
English.
What if there was a way or will it be
the language to Teesha would be most
beneficial for them down there?
So language wise is really
tough because when they speak,
there's over 200 spoken
languages in Congo,
over 200.
There's five national languages.
Uh,
the government and schools and hospitals,
uh,
is French,
has colonized by Belgium.
Uh,
and it's,
that's a nuts story.
Um,
but then,
uh,
they also speak Swahili in the east.
Um,
they speak Lingala in the west.
Uh,
they speak bannock Kongo and
there's one more that I'm missing.
Um,
when you talk to them,
how do you,
what do you talk to them more?
So I very,
very broken a Swahili,
very,
very broken Swahili,
but the Swahili they speak there is,
um,
it's mixed with a little bit of French.
Um,
and also,
uh,
the local language.
So you,
you've got to truly live there.
And over the last six years,
I've been there for about
maybe a year and seven,
eight,
you're nine months,
uh,
boots on the ground.
I'm a year at one time and then a man,
but,
but the,
the saying about Swahili is
that it was born in Tanzania.
It got sick and Kenya died in Uganda
and they took it to the Congo to bury it
because they can't
communicate with anyone.
And you've got another,
I mean,
not,
not truly communicate and
get their point across.
So it's really tough teaching them
English is teaching them how to read.
Like I just think that if you could
somehow another teach them some language
where they could read and
write things down and you like,
you could just keep the,
keep this thing going with
them while they're there.
What,
what I think is really cool is now,
um,
we,
we've got this video up on,
it's on youtube.
It's chiefly Omaze transformation.
And so chief Leo May,
uh,
in his village,
it was just an incredible transformation.
They had never owned land of their own,
but chiefly,
oh,
Mae remembered his grandfather used to
actually take him to hunt on that land
that they now own.
And so,
uh,
now it's theirs and his grandson's
going to be able to say,
you know,
this was my grandfather's land.
Just like he's able to say,
you know,
I used to hunt with my grandfather here,
but um,
so from the land that they have,
they have land,
water and food there.
They have about 500 acres I believe.
And so then they have their own water and
now they've grown so many banana trees
there.
They used to get paid one to two bananas
a day for Labor from sunup to sundown,
a banana or two a day.
Now they have hundreds and
hundreds of banana trees.
I mean probably five,
600 banana trees and that one village.
And from that they're able to go sell it.
When they sell it,
they can buy their own
clothes for the first time.
They cannot now pay school fees so that
they can actually go to the local school
and learn to read and write.
It's a little bit of a hike for them,
but they can go learn and read and write.
And so it's the first time that,
I mean it could even create
an opportunity for them,
a boothy pygmies to have representation
at their version of Congress in the
Congo for the first time ever,
there's over 200 tribes represented there.
The only one not represented
is the my booty pygmies.
And so to get them educated,
the excuse he used to be
from the government was,
they're not,
they're not really people.
They're part man,
part animal.
That was the government saying that
I think in the early two thousands,
maybe the late nineties,
early two thousands,
they're saying they were half man,
half animal that they'll
never have representation.
But now it started to shift to
where we even have a governor,
the governor of the
largest state in Congo,
um,
sponsoring everything we do,
you know,
endorsing it,
saying,
Hey,
you have free range of the tree region
and we want you to drill here and we want
you to drill there.
And so he's actually come
on our side and said,
what the work you guys are doing is
really great because it's through the
locals,
it's locally led.
Um,
and so to have that opportunity,
once some of the [inaudible]
pygmies are educated,
have a high school education,
maybe we can get them
to a local university.
They're right next door,
maybe in Uganda,
Rwanda,
Kenya,
um,
then they can go back and they can
actually start representing themselves.
Um,
because now they say if they're educated,
then we can't.
But none of them are educated.
So I would draw out the process longer,
but now they're the,
you know,
the next generation will be,
and that's what's inspired
you also to get back into MMA.
Yeah.
And that inspired you
to sign up with bell.
And since then you've had three fights,
three fights,
and won all three,
and now you're one of the top
Bellator heavyweight contenders.
Yeah.
It was kind of crazy because
when we first talked,
you hadn't fought in a long
time and you were five years,
two months.
Yeah.
And you weren't training.
You were just kind of like going
back and forth to the Congo and then,
you know,
that had to be a crazy thing to just get
back into it after all that time out.
It was the hardest thing I've ever done.
Um,
physically at least I'm sure to get
yourself back in that kind of shape in
between my first and second fight back,
I had malaria again.
Um,
and that was my third time to have that.
He's got malaria three times folks.
And so that time I got malaria while
I was there because it was so bad.
I broke out in shingles,
um,
which,
you know,
being 30 just now turning 30.
So then I was like 28 or 29,
um,
to have shingles.
The doctor's like,
you're too young for this.
And my body was just that
stress down for shingles.
Yeah,
I get people getting shingles.
Well I guess normally that
might be like met herpes,
something like that.
But they did the culture or whatever and
it was shingles and it's supposed to be
an older generation thing I think.
And uh,
no kidding.
I didn't know shingles.
Is it because they say it
starts like 40 and beyond,
is it a compromised immune issue is out.
It is the idea.
And so it's,
it's actually chicken pox
coming back out and your body.
So if you haven't had chicken pox,
you cap shingles.
And so it's like it lays dormant in your
body and then once you get into older
age or your immune system is compromised,
then shingles can,
that is the most fucked up thing about
the human body that it harbors these
bacterias and they sit there waiting,
just fuck up your life.
Yeah.
And so then I had,
oh man,
dude,
I had that.
Then I had shingles and then I came back
and for a month or two months or the
doctors are trying to figure out what
was wrong with me because I was clear on
malaria.
Um,
but the CDC to,
to test on me for malaria again,
but they found out I had
dengue fever every night.
I was going to sleep.
I was waking up and that was probably,
did you tell him you ate a monkey?
I did.
And then they wanted,
they wanted to do the
corn team thing on me.
Um,
and so,
but it had been over
three months since I had,
since a bullet had broken out.
And it had been three months
since I've been back into a bowl.
A bowl was like,
you're going to kill us all.
Just like a year ago.
Everybody's freaking out of that one
lady who was a nurse who wouldn't be
quarantined.
She's like,
fuck you,
I'm going outside.
Like,
no,
she's going to kill us
all you selfish bitch.
So,
so a Bolo was actually
discovered in Congo.
There's a river called the Ebola river.
Oh,
great.
Um,
and so that's,
that's where it was discovered and it
actually came back and broke out since the
big crazy one.
It broke out and I think it was
like less than a hundred people.
It might have been like 10 or less.
And so they really were
able to contain it,
which is impressive to be able to do in
Congo because it's not as organized as,
as anywhere else.
Um,
but yeah,
so man,
but on the MMA journey back,
it was,
it was really,
really tough.
I mean,
the muscle memory just was not there.
I had lost the wrestling I grew up with,
um,
and the cardio obviously wasn't
there after five years off.
Um,
but the sicknesses,
other things,
my body was healed.
Uh,
the muscles and joints and
ligaments and all that.
I think a,
I felt better than ever there.
It was just the muscle
memory wasn't coming back.
And,
um,
the cardio is really tough and I had
to shed some weight and get healthy.
The muscles in the cartilage,
in the joints and everything like that,
they're probably benefited
from all that time off.
Right.
I think so a lot.
Cause somebody guys get,
by the time you're 30,
I mean,
how many MMA fighters or just have like
really huge injuries by the time you're
30,
31 years old,
it's pretty common.
You got to start.
I started fighting,
uh,
at 19 years old,
professionally MMA.
And so,
um,
and I was always the young guy
in the heavyweight division.
Um,
and so now just turning 30,
I feel like you've got a lot of miles
left on me having those five years off.
And so life experience too,
right?
Yeah.
And I honestly think a
lot of people are like,
oh,
so you didn't,
you took off.
And that's probably impossible for me.
It was a whole other kind of training.
I mean Kinda like I was talking about
Raphael and the being comfortable being
uncomfortable.
I mean I've slept in the mud.
A woke up in the mud,
at least slept on the dirt,
woke up in the mud because the rain
came so hard and sleeping under tweaking
leaf huts on the dirt,
you know,
no,
no mattress underneath,
you know,
anything.
Um,
and so me and have that to
battle through the sicknesses to,
to see what they suffer from and
how they dig deep on a daily basis.
Um,
they're,
they're in survival mode and
the see the battles they fight.
And then to have,
you know,
32 of my heroes
there that have drilled 70 wells that
whenever a bridge collapses because a
truck is illegally logging
and they overloaded their,
their weight and they just collapsed
this 1930s bridge and then I think,
oh,
it's going to be impossible.
And then they get out of the truck,
they start walking through the water
with all our welding equipment and we're
going to find another way.
We're going to get a taxi motorcycles to,
to ride in everything we
needed this big truck,
uh,
to carry on.
And so it's going to take a lot longer.
It's going to be a lot harder,
but we're going to get it done
or we're going to win this fight.
So you feel like that was a
training sort of tool for yeah,
I mean,
I'm not going to say this,
but,
um,
or I don't want to compare it to this,
but it's almost like a,
it was a life experience and kind
of like some of our navy guys,
Navy seals,
and they do the special forces training.
Um,
I think this was my version of like
kind of special training for me as a
fighter.
It enlargened,
uh,
my heart or deepen the well of who I am.
Um,
and so I think I just
have more of a motivation,
uh,
to go in there.
And when the name of the Guy Action
game has really come up a lot now,
yeah,
it does still have the wrestling and
now my submission game is on point being
you're a blue belt now under Lavato rice.
Yeah.
And uh,
and I wanted to do it the right way.
I want to do it the way that
every other student does it.
And so it was,
it was really cool to get that.
I didn't know that that
would mean so much to me,
but it,
but it really did.
Yeah,
it's nuts man.
It's nuts.
How that war that,
that promotion,
um,
is a milestone in my martial arts journey.
That's why it's so good for kids.
Martial arts are so good for kids
because it gives them a tangible
representation of their hard work.
Like you get,
give them a belt and a tie on that belt
and have this giant smile on my face.
You know,
when my kids,
my kids take martial arts
and when they get a new belt,
they have this giant smile on their face.
They're so happy to jump around.
They look at it,
they want to wear it home.
And that was me squeeze it.
Yeah,
me too,
man.
I remember when I got my blue belt,
I was like,
Holy Shit,
I'm not a white belt anymore.
Yes.
You know,
you feel like I made it
over the hump and the,
what they say is if you
could make it to purple belt,
you can make it a black belt.
That's the blue belt is like,
you're just working hard.
If you work hard,
you get there.
Hey,
you know,
you're not,
you're not ed white belt anymore,
but if you can get to purple belt,
like,
Hey man,
just keep going and you can be a black
belt in Lovato's school of Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu.
It says I'm a black belt as
a white belt who never quit.
Yeah,
I've heard that before.
I like it,
man.
It's an interesting time
now for Jujitsu and MMA.
It really is because you're
seeing like some guys like,
uh,
this weekend,
Brian or teas.
Hmm.
Um,
or Tayga rather.
Brian Ortega is fighting a cub.
Swanson and Brian Ortega tease.
I'm trying to remember his name.
Nickname t city.
Tisa triangle city.
He's got one of the best guards in MMA.
Yeah.
An Ortega is fucking nasty
off of his back.
I mean,
he's just,
he's so good.
You think you loads of them to sleep with
his baby blue eyes and then he locked
space,
beautiful face as long
flowing locks just like you.
Yeah.
So Brian is,
um,
in my opinion,
probably the best guy in the
division off of his back.
I don't think there's anybody that could
fuck with him at one 45 especially now
that Charles Olivera is moved up to a 55.
I think he's the best at 45.
His fucking submission game
is so lightening lightening
fast and just tight as
can be.
But cubs Swanson's a black belt in
Brazilian Jujitsu to and Carb is a nasty
striker to and super unorthodox,
like real weird.
But Brian is a fucking great striker to
and Brian is an motherfucking defeated
12 and older with a one no contest.
So,
um,
I'm an interesting fight.
Fuck yet is,
it's,
it's like,
uh,
you know,
it's,
it's a real crossroads
fight in a lot of ways.
Cause cub is at the top of the
heap and the 145 pound division,
he's lost to some of the big guys.
Like Max Holloway lost a Frankie Edgar.
But he's still really respected and
thought of as one of the top guys in the
division and Ortega being this young
prodigy at 12 and now has this opportunity
now to fight one of the most
crafty veterans in the division.
I like.
It sounds like a similar
opportunity that Nigga just had.
Francis just had,
you know to,
to be that young lion you have to
come up and around the guy and really
announced himself as one of
the top contenders or tell
you can submit anybody in
the world.
I really believe that and he,
he'll box with you too.
The thing about Ortega is like he'll
make it seem like there is no intention
whatsoever to go to the ground and then
sometimes he boxes guys up and then when
they want to take him to the ground
because they don't like to stand up,
that's when they're Foxville.
He's got an interesting strategy in that
regard because in the last fight I was
thinking like,
wow,
this is kind of interesting.
We're in the third round.
He's still has not tried
to submit this guy.
Like,
that's his game.
And then boom,
they go to the ground and he instantly
catches him with a good team.
But the reason they went to the ground,
his opponent took him down cause
he didn't like the stand up.
That's smart.
Yeah.
So his strategy,
his standup keeps coming up
higher and higher and higher.
But when it comes to Jujitsu,
he's one of the very best in the sport.
He's really good.
How far away is he from here?
Where he trains?
He's close.
He's in black house,
black houses in Compton.
Um,
or that area.
So it's,
I don't know if it's exactly Compton,
Compton adjacent,
but uh,
so there's that go to the,
go to the two to 19 card.
Oh,
you know what,
go to the fucking,
um,
the Fox card.
That's a big one.
That is,
yeah,
that one right there.
Oh Man.
Robbie Lawler Hofeld dose on Joe's good
lightweight and welterweight champ.
Yeah,
man,
that is fucking into arresting
and he's been doing so great man.
Yeah,
well like Lovato,
I mean a Dolson Joe's,
what he has done,
um,
in going up from one 45 one 55 to one 70,
there was like,
well he was the champ,
but he lost Eddie Alvarez.
Well,
let's see how he does a one seven.
He looks way better.
I mean steamrolling
people the way fucked up.
Neil Magni long kicked him to the ground,
took him to the ground,
smushed him.
I mean he beat Terrick Safa
Dean and a stand up fight,
which is like,
wow.
Safa Dean is world class striker.
Neil Neil's a buddy of mine
and he is an absolute monster.
And to,
I've seen that fight.
Rafael dos Anjos looks
incredible at this weight.
Yeah,
he's uh,
that's,
it's very interesting cause I think
he's supposed to be at one 70 all along.
It's not like he's a big one 55
or that's made it up to one 70.
But he's kind of small and 70 no,
he looks like a one 70 and
of course east fighting,
one of the best ones,
seventies ever in the form of champ,
Robbie Lawler.
So that that should be
a perfect fight for Fox.
Cause uh,
you know,
just to,
for fun.
I mean it's going to be
a chaotic fight for it.
There's never been a goddamn
boring Robbie Lawler fight ever.
Yeah.
You know,
he doesn't even know how
to have a boring fight.
Very,
very,
very true.
What do you think of the lamas fight?
I like it,
but llamas was obviously training for,
um,
for Aldo.
Right.
And so,
uh,
you know,
he gets this change of guard.
Now he's fighting Josh Emett who's a,
who's a tough customer and Emmett,
a lot of people don't know him,
but he's 12 and one.
It's a good fight.
Very good fight.
I'm excited.
See how that goes out.
Yeah.
I'm excited about that.
But I'm also excited about the
pons and Novio Mike Perry fight.
Yeah.
I almost want this fight to just happen.
So Darren till can fight Mike Perry.
I'm like,
I'm almost like rooting for Mike
Perry just so he can get out of it.
And they can make that
Darren till Mike Perry fight.
Cause if they do decide to make that,
because I know they tried to make Mike
Perry versus Wonderboy and Dana even
announced it and,
and Wonderboy was like,
hey,
slow the fuck down.
Like the guy had one fight in the UFC.
I just fought for the
title twice and then beat,
um,
uh,
Jorge,
Mazda doll.
Right.
And then you're going to have me
fight this guy like right away.
Like this is crazy.
And by the way,
my thumbs hurt.
He had like injuries in his thumbs.
He was like,
he got his thumbs were,
it was talking about it after
the fight that he fucked up,
the tenant is in its thumbs.
When I was interviewing him,
he was like,
something happened in my hand
and I thought it broke it.
I'm not sure.
So he's got,
he's got a lot of arrest to,
to go through.
So Darren tills looking for an opponent
and they were talking about Darren till
versus [inaudible] Guzman,
which is very exciting as well because
Camaros Guzman who slated go to UFC two
19 loose mon is slated to fight against,
um,
meek mill.
I've known him since we were 15.
It was my,
we grew up wrestling together a meal.
Meek mill's a rapper and
he smells the rapper.
Right?
Yeah.
What the Fuck's wrong with me?
A meal.
Meek who is a,
the,
the crazy Viking
motherfucker in highschool.
People called Huseman us man.
Some reason.
Uh,
but
that's because of the way it's spelled.
Yeah.
But he was a terrifying guy.
He is.
He's one of the most
terrifying guys in the sport.
What I love seeing is
I think in high school,
our senior year,
I think he graduated,
or sorry,
I you finish his senior year,
fourth in the state of Texas.
Um,
so number four and in wrestling,
uh,
and then he went on to
UNK or Nebraska Carney and
never fought meek mill,
make a meal.
Meek is a scary guy,
was really looking forward to this fight.
And then there was some talk of the
fight night taking place because Amil
couldn't get his visa,
set it out,
sorted out.
But then he got it sorted
out and Comacho loose.
Mom was saying,
Hey,
you know,
I've already moved on.
And then so lately a meal,
Meeks,
Instagram and a Twitter has been calling,
oops.
Monnet chicken and saying he's ducking
him and all kinds of crazy shit.
So I do not know if this is official.
I'm hoping this is official because
someone needs to challenge [inaudible].
I think [inaudible] is one of the most
dangerous and scary guys in the division
and he's not being talked about.
So one of the top 10 that he's,
he's earned that spot,
I think.
I believe so too.
There's so many tough guys in that
division that he's sort of kind of been
overlooked in my opinion.
And to me,
when I watch him fight,
I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
this guy's a handful for everybody.
I think.
Ooh,
smoke.
Pull that card back up please.
I think,
oops,
mon is just a,
he's got all the tools.
He's in his prime.
He's fucking super dangerous everywhere.
Super Dangerous.
Standing up,
smashes people on the ground.
Really fucking strong for the division.
Top game out of control.
You know,
we don't know what happens
when he gets put on his back.
We don't know what
happens if he gets tagged.
If he fights a world class
striker that could stand up.
But what a meek mill
brings to the table a meal.
Meek is,
I did it again.
What uh,
a meal meek brings to the table is
nasty power and a real warrior spirit.
Yeah.
He came into the UFC after
a Kale victory over who?
Some are Paul Harris.
Yeah,
I remember I watched that.
I was like get this guy in the UFC please.
Yeah,
like he's a fucking animal.
And the thing is everybody's
running away from tomorrow.
Ooh,
smart.
Except a meal.
Meek and maybe meek mill.
We haven't asked him.
He said Colby Covington
stuff and I'm too right now.
Oh,
I'm a come out.
What?
We sponsored that.
Yeah,
of course he has.
Everybody's ducking him.
But also Colby would be wise because
Colbys made so much noise after beating
Damien Maia and try,
he's trying to get a
fight with Tyron Woodley.
He's trying to like,
he's trying to promote himself and the
the worst way to promote yourself as to
fight tomorrow.
It was wa
but a meal.
Meek is like,
get me in there,
bitch.
Let's do it.
So I,
I sincerely hope that this fight
actually takes place because I think,
uh,
I think it's a fucking wicked,
wicked fight.
And I want to see if,
uh,
a meal has any answers for the problems
Kamara Guzman brings to the octagon
because no one has so far.
And I mean,
he's got one loss in his record.
I do not know if that was in
the UFC or outside the EOC,
but in the last few fights we've seen
him since he's won the ultimate fighter.
He's just been unstoppable.
But again,
not getting the credit that he deserves.
Yeah,
it's all,
all of his fights inside the
octagon seem to be all victories.
He,
he's one of the most naturally
athletic guys that I've ever known.
That's what I meant by
grown up wrestling with him.
He started wrestling in high school
and finished fourth in the state.
But then you went onto the
NCAAs division two and just one,
two,
I think two national titles
or maybe three and a,
he's a stud with a big fight for me
on this card is not just a title fight
between Cyborg and Holly Holm.
But yeah,
that one,
Khabib never got Madoff versus Edson
Barboza come on son number two and number
three in the lightweight division,
which is the most stacked division,
I think it's like
lightweight and welterweight.
A lady,
the two most stack divisions,
but it's hard to,
it's hard to pick which
one is most stacked.
But Jesus Christ,
I like this fight,
like this fight a lot.
And Apparently Nijmegen Madoff has a new,
according to Daniel Cormier,
he told me number Madoff has a new
conditioning guy and a new or a new,
a Dietitian guy knew nutrition
guy and a nice dessert,
no Tiramisu.
It's backing off the Tiramisu.
He's uh,
got,
um,
you know,
on a very strict diet plan and he's
far lighter than he's ever been.
And we're headed into this fight,
this fight as in what,
two weeks now?
The 30th and today is three weeks away.
So very exciting.
Very interesting.
I'm fucking pumped for that fight because
Barboza is one of the best strikers in
the division for sure.
And it could be,
can't do anything wrong on the feet
because Ed's and I light him up for sure.
I mean this is the best striker for sure.
The best striker that could be,
it was fought.
He fought Michael Johnson who's a good
striker and Michael Johnson caught him
and tagged them and had them rock.
And it was the first time we saw any
adversity whatsoever or any real,
a real struggle for Khabib.
But he went on to dominate that fine.
He took him to the ground,
just beat the shit out of him.
And He's 24 and o,
which is unprecedented,
you know,
24 and oh and just been
steamroll in everybody.
So it's only like 30 right,
29 30 something like that.
I do not know his age,
but I feel like he's not
even in his prime yet.
What,
how,
what does it say here?
29 yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
he's like,
he's like right at the door and let
him know he's had a bunch of injuries.
But if he can,
if he can get healthy and stay healthy,
man,
it's gonna be scary.
Seemingly does.
Yeah.
For Barboza it's all about just
keeping the fight standing.
And Barboza has wicked leg kicks.
He's the only guy in the UFC that stopped.
Two guys with leg kicks.
Um,
he stopped a hot fail.
Aloe Vera with leg kicks and Mike Lulo,
both those guys.
You stopped with leg.
How do I remember that?
I don't know.
But uh,
his,
uh,
his leg kicks are amongst the fastest
I've ever seen in any division.
His switch kick,
fastest switch kick I've ever seen
to fucking ridiculous when he,
when he lights it up,
like off that left leg,
you like cheese us.
Like it's like he's,
he's getting there with half the time
that most worldclass fighters get there.
Would that kick?
So that's uh,
that's interesting.
Spinning Oak,
he'll kick it as fast as most people.
Just normal head kick.
Yeah,
his spinning shit's out of control.
He's just a ridiculous striker.
But it's all about Norma coming off,
getting him to the ground,
the questions he's going to
be all stuff to take down.
What's the strategy they have
for this guy on the feet?
Are they going to have them open up
and possibly give up that take down or
they're going to have,
I'm cautious and just throwing punches
and just constantly worried about the
take down defense cause Nermana Madoff is,
he has been unchallenged when
it comes to the grappling.
He's so God damn strong.
It's Chris Dominant.
Well even guys like Dos Anjos,
he's a black belt in Jujitsu.
He usually puts the smush on people,
you know,
know my gun off,
puts the smush on him.
He gets guys to break too.
Like you see it in their face.
They're like,
fuck,
I can't do anything against this guy.
He grew up doing it to bears,
so that's why for real look legitimate.
Yeah.
My wife didn't believe that so I had to
pull it up and show her and she's like,
what are,
what are they doing to him?
Why?
That's how baby,
why make that baby fight a bear?
I was like six,
seven,
eight years old.
There's just biting them in the R.
Yeah.
Jimmy Rivera versus John Linacre.
That's a fucking great fight too.
That's up in the right hand corner there.
Ooh,
that's a good fight.
That's a real good fight.
Jimmy Rivera has looked insanely good at
135 especially that victory over Uriah
Faber.
I was super impressed with that.
I was like,
wow.
Like this guy is for real.
I knew it was for real before,
but Rivera was supposed to
be fighting Dominick Cruz,
but Dominick Cruz broke his arm and
training and so now he's fighting John
Linacre,
who's a scary fucking guy at one 35.
Yeah.
I like this a lot for Jimmy
because you can just hear every,
every interview he does.
He's just hungry.
Hungry for the chance to be world champ.
Yeah.
It's exciting to see this.
Why haven't I like it too?
And there's interesting,
um,
Tj Dillashaw just shut John Linacre down.
I mean,
completely shut down his offense and
almost was like having beautiful,
beautiful,
beautiful.
I mean,
it was a perfect example of
how you play the matador.
Like a,
like a technical matador.
I mean,
that was what,
one of his finest performances
because Linacre is fucking terrifying.
Like everybody's in a war with Linacre,
you know,
like,
uh,
Ian McCall,
like everybody who fights Linacre winds
up being these goddamn waterfront.
Um,
so many,
so many guys,
they get in there with him and they get
hit by him and you just see it on their
face.
Like Jesus Christ,
he's one of the few guys that
actually earn that nickname.
Tens of stone.
Yeah.
Francisco,
they're out.
Like so many guys,
he's fought,
he cracks them and you see
the look in their eyes like,
Oh,
Christ.
Um,
so he beat Oh,
oh,
okay.
He beat the Marlin Vera,
which is a very good fight.
The TJ Dillashaw loss,
I think was the most telling because Tj
Dillashaw figured out a way how to solve
that puzzle when John Dodson couldn't,
which was really interesting.
John Dodson lost two Linacre when Dotson
was thought to be one of the best guys
in the division at one 35.
And he lost him.
But a split decision,
you know,
he fucked up Michael McDonald and
the fight before that and he's just,
he says something special man,
you know,
he really is.
He's,
um,
he's a a tank of a guy.
But I really honestly believe that,
uh,
Jimmy Rivera is world class and I think
this is a good opportunity for him to
fight against,
uh,
a big scary tank of a guy
in John Lineker and uh,
and show his,
his,
his talent and his ability.
I think it's a real test I want,
I'm really interesting to see,
really interested to see how this
works out because Rivera's not like a,
an elusive Tj Dillashaw type guy.
He's an attacker.
So how is he going to,
you know,
what is he going to do with Linacre?
Is he gonna chop the legs?
He's going to attack from
below like you did with Uriah?
Like he fucked the rise leg up real
early in that fight to the port where it
really limited your eyes.
Mobility.
That's a,
that's an interesting fight.
I like that fight a lot.
Carlos condit returns gets Magni Don Don,
that's interesting to Carlos had
been out for quite a long time.
I want to say two years.
Yeah.
Click on his thing.
Let's find out when
was the last fight was,
I want to say it was about two years ago,
didn't he?
He lost his Damien Maia and say that he
was talking about retirement or he was
retiring then?
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
August,
2016 so not quite that long ago.
And then,
um,
before that he lost the
Robbie Lawler fight,
which was a crazy five round war
and he lost a split decision.
PTL Go and lost the tie Tyron.
So I mean,
those,
the victory over Tiago was phenomenal.
We caught him with that elbow.
Yeah.
Murderer's row of his last opponents,
man.
Yeah.
And they'll tie the Tyron
Woodley losses by injury.
It says k Tko Tko but the reality is
tyrin hidden with a brutal leg kick and is
a,
he's a knee blew out.
Yeah.
What switches be.
Apparently he had heard it before,
but the power that Tyron Woodley has
in his fucking leg kicks like co Rice.
Tyron Woodley had some choice
words about Colby Covington too.
Yeah,
he was uh,
you know,
talking about Colby like campaigning,
hard to get the fight and talking
all kinds of crazy shit about him.
But Tyron was saying like this,
first of all,
everything he's saying about our
training sessions is 100% bullshit.
And he's like,
when I get that dude in the octagon,
if he ever does get that shot,
he goes,
I am going to fuck him up.
He was Colby Covington is never going
to fight again after he fazes me.
That's what he said.
Yeah,
he was.
We were talking before the weigh ins.
We were standing around the octagon before
the Wayans past UFC in Detroit and he
was,
he was like shaking his head.
He's like,
I am going to fuck that dude up.
he does not understand.
He's not on my level.
He's talking to all kinds of shit.
He's,
you know,
writing all these checks that there's
no way he's fucking talent can cache.
And when I get them in there,
I'm going to smash him.
And he goes,
I'm going to take my time on him.
I'm gonna try to hurt him.
He,
this is what he said to me.
This is crazy.
He goes,
I have never tried to hit anyone
with all my power in the octagon.
And I'm like,
wait,
what?
How is that possible?
He sends people flying across the aisle,
watch his fight with Jay Hiran.
Oh yeah,
you can,
you can hit somebody harder than that.
Are you sure?
Cause that's,
that doesn't seem normal.
That doesn't seem right.
Talking about his leg kicks.
I was just gonna ask you,
what'd you think of being
there for the gates?
He Alvarez.
That was great.
Gosh,
it was amazing.
There was two fights that night that made,
there was,
there were humbling.
Um,
that was one of them.
God fight was humbling,
like the fucking guts and glory.
Watching those guys go at it.
But Yancey Madeiros and cal by
Oliveira might've been even crazier.
I think that was the
craziest fight of the night.
And I believe that one
performance of the night,
thank the baby Jesus,
because if it didn't,
there was some criminal shenanigans afoot.
It was the craziest fight ever.
They one would get rocked and the other
would get rocked and you'd think the
fight was over.
And then the other one come back,
a rock,
the other one.
And then finally Yancey
one and the third round.
I mean,
it was just a fucking k odic war.
It was such a good fight.
Just such a good fight to bonuses
to fight of the night awards.
That's nice.
See,
that's what I love about the UFC when,
when people really perform and
lay it on the line like that,
but did Allah did Haldo uh,
although in Holloway,
when any sort of a fight of the night,
I know Francis didn't,
but they said they're,
yeah,
they're going to hook them
up with some sort of a bonus.
Yeah.
How do you not give
that Guy Kao the night?
What,
what are we doing here?
What is it?
What's that say?
It just says that those two got fight at,
doesn't say anything about anything else.
Oh,
okay.
Does it says that fight,
that fight of the night?
No,
no,
no.
Gay G and Cowboy Oliveira.
Yancey Madeiros got fight of the night.
Well,
Max Holloway's performance was
nothing short of masterful,
nothing short of masterful
the way he handled the Aldo,
the way he,
he,
he yelled at me after the first round.
He gets done with the f,
the round that he runs.
He's going back to his end.
He looks at me,
goes,
the man is tired.
The man is tired.
He's a motherfucker,
dude.
Max Holloway is a real fucking warrior.
I mean to the core.
That guy relishes it.
He loves it.
When he was like,
like chicken neck in it all,
he's got his hands down.
He's talking shit to
them and stocking them.
You could see it in all of
those face like he was drowning.
He would see the waves were,
and he knew he wasn't going to be
able to dog paddle for too long.
Like he's like Jesus Christ.
Like,
how am I going to keep up with this guy?
And the thing about Max Holloway,
it's so interesting is
he's in a lot of ways,
he has that sort of Nick Diaz approach
where he's not hitting you with all of
his mind.
He's not throwing these haymakers unless
he's got you hurt until he's got you
hurt.
Once he's got you hurt,
then he's just fucking
whip and bombs your way.
But until then,
he's just constantly on you
just constantly peppering
you caused on your kit,
knee punch,
move forward,
and you're just dealing with
him and trying to breathe.
You don't get any breath.
And he just keeps that pressure on you.
And he knew all those fading right now.
And I'll tell you all to look
good in that first round.
I thought he was going to start picking
it up like almost the old with the leg
kicks he should have,
he should have gone,
his strategy should have been
almost entirely leg kick centered.
Right.
And he was trying to catch him and he
caught him with a couple of good punches.
But all of his punches are sprints,
right.
And if he doesn't knock
you out with those sprints,
like he only has so many
of those in the gas tank,
you're fighting the guy that can do it
for a marathon and he and he can and Max
Holloway,
Ken,
he is so well conditioned and so aware
of visibility and not stretching himself.
So when they got to the third,
he started slugging it out with all
those at the very beginning of the third.
He's like,
I know this guy's tired.
He goes,
I'm going to make them sprint with me.
And you could see like as the,
the beginning of the
third round played out,
all doe was swinging wild.
Adam and I was watching this,
I was a,
I was going like this is not conservative.
Like he's not conserving
his energy at all.
What he's doing is trying to take Max
Holloway out with one shot and he's
blowing out his entire wad doing this.
And then you saw Holloway just coming
out common on common on just bang,
Bang,
pop,
pop and all of those trying to move
his head and he's using all his head
movement,
but he never gets a break.
Yeah,
it's an incredible pace.
That Halloween,
incredible.
It doesn't give you any space.
You don't get any rest.
You don't get it.
He does.
There's no lay in back with Holloway.
Max Holloway's on you,
on you,
on you.
I love what he said about
fighting Aldo in Rio too.
He goes,
that's what kings do.
they go to the other person's
village and they'd take the crown.
It's like,
Ooh,
it's right.
That's what they do.
That's what he did.
He's the baddest motherfucker.
I think he's the best one 45 forever.
I mean,
he might not agree with it
yet because of the record,
which I see.
I see his point,
but the way he fights the,
the octagon Iq that he shows his,
his fight Iq is ability to find a weakness
and to see it as predatory behavior
inside the octagon.
I think he's the best.
I really do.
I just think I,
it's so impressive to me that he's not
like Aldo in his prime was spectacular
and amazingly impressive.
Like his flying knee first
round knock out of Cub Swanson,
the knockout of Chad Mendez,
you know,
I mean he's,
he's uh,
the,
the Uriah fight,
we brutalize
your rise leg.
I mean,
he's unquestionably one
of the greats of all time,
but in my opinion,
skill wise,
Max Holloway has now surpassed him.
I think he's the best.
Yeah.
What are your takes hoot or who do you
have for the ability for heavyweight
tournament?
I'm fucking very curious about that.
First of all,
I thought it was really interesting they
decided to go with Michio owned versus
Roy Nelson.
Right.
I thought that was interesting
because first of all,
Mitch reone just knocked
out fade or right.
Wouldn't you like want to see that again?
Like it doesn't fit his fate or want to
see that again cause Mitre Jones fight
and Frank Mir,
I do not know what kind of
testing that Beltour is employing,
but I hope it's wild west style testing.
I hope they pee in a cup.
Hold it up to the light and
if nothing swimming in it,
they go,
you're good.
Let them roll.
Yeah.
I'm kind of campaigning right now.
It'd be the alternate.
So I would love,
love,
love to be the alternate in return.
What is your ranking in the
Bellator heavyweight division?
Right now they have one.
I'm not sure that they
really have an official one,
so,
um,
but I'm,
you know,
I think if,
if I'm not in there for
this as the alternate,
I think that I'll be one of the first
title defenses and I'll be hoping for,
and I'll say active,
I'm gonna fight,
hopefully I'll pick it up to
two to three fights a year.
And King Mo is in the heavyweight
tournament with Ryan Bader.
That's the light heavyweight
champion that's gonna happen in May.
It's chill versus rampage January.
Uh,
then it's the,
the Roy Nelson and Matt
Mitrione and February.
And then they have the
fade or versus Frank Mir,
um,
in April.
So they're going to
take a break and March,
don't think I don't like about this is
it locks everybody up for a long ass
time.
Like,
I would like it if that was all on like
two shows or maybe even one crazy card,
you know,
have all the fights on one car.
I think Mir has to wait until April.
So it was that contract.
I think it's the testing that
he had in the UFC and then,
uh,
all the test and validate or don't do it.
And so I think he's suspended
until April and then it can fight.
And so,
but that,
that fight,
I think probably a lot
of fans 10 years ago,
but,
but now two are going to be really excited
to see Mir versus fate or you know,
to kind of legendary champions.
Um,
and then,
uh,
I don't know why the Bader one and
king mo ones all the way back in May,
but I think most had some pretty
significant injuries that he's had to deal
with.
And Bader just fought recently,
so maybe he needed some time to,
um,
but yeah,
maybe it's the injuries
with Mo and by man.
I'm excited.
So I'm,
I'm just training and ready to jump in.
I'm a,
I'm actually getting to go
climb Mount Kilimanjaro.
Maybe I will actually,
I'm,
I'm deciding on it this next week to see
if I can submit the alternate position
or not.
To me,
the big one is Rory Macdonald.
Douglas Lema.
That's the big one.
Yeah,
that's the January.
That's the big one.
That's going to be big.
That's the one where I'm like,
okay.
Cause I feel like when it comes
the welterweight division,
Bella Tor has two guys
and Lima and in the sea,
the Lima thing,
the only thing that stands out in the
Lima thing is Ben Aspirin was Ben her and
it was a long time ago,
no doubt about it.
But Ben asked her and just had his way
with Lima and had his way with Korskoff
has his way with all these guys that to
me and Ben's coming on the podcast next
month.
We got them scheduled.
Awesome.
Uh,
before or after,
I forget which one,
the,
uh,
event out here,
the bell tour event.
But I feel like that is,
I mean,
now that he's retired,
that is my biggest regret
that he didn't get in MMA,
that he didn't get into the UFC.
My biggest regret.
I wish I could have worked that out.
Whatever it was.
Fuck.
I wanted to see what would happen.
You want to see what happens
with him and Tyron Woodley.
You want to see what happens with him
and worldclass wrestlers were also
knockout artists.
You want to see what happens with him
and the elite of the elite at one 70 in
the octagon and for whatever reason,
and I'm sure he'll tell us
and I'm sure he'll be very,
very outspoken.
Yeah.
I wonder if it's the,
the whole style thing.
I mean like the hardcore fans,
the hardcore fans love it,
but then it's almost like a,
I won't use his name,
but I know a fighter that fought in
the upper weight classes in the UFC,
you know,
nine or 10 wins and only
two losses and gets cut.
Um,
and so it's almost like,
you know,
you got to be with that.
Um,
Jared Rochelle.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
great guy,
awesome training partner,
great fighter.
But he had some fights.
Why did he get cut?
That was after just a,
he had an early loss in the UFC and
then he went on a tear and then he had
another loss and they cut them one loss.
Yeah,
that seems crazy.
So I think he had like eight,
eight,
nine or 10 wins and only two losses there.
And then,
so it was after one loss and he was gone.
So I believe it was
because of the style style.
But he's Batman,
man.
That styles legitimate though.
The problem is you can't decide
that you need things to be exciting.
You need things.
You're your sport is
things being effective.
The whole idea is like,
here you go,
you got a guy like Francis in Ghana who
can knock anybody's head into another
dimension.
Right?
Well what happens if Francis in Gando
gets mothered by some Rulon Gardner type
character?
Rochelle.
Yeah.
Some giant dude who grabs a hold to him,
dragged him to the ground and
fucking hammer fists item for three,
five rounds.
You know,
like you don't,
you want to see that?
I want it.
I want to know that
this kind of guy can be,
can be immobilized,
that he can be neutralized.
And we've seen Ben her and do that to
really like Korskoff and Lima to fucking
straight up assassins right.
We've seen him do that.
So um,
I wanted to see him try to fight like
some of the elite of the elite because I
think that style is critical.
The,
the wrestling style is the hardest style
to deal with if you can't compete with
the wrestler.
That's why I've always had,
if you had like a pyramid
of all the techniques in martial arts,
like what would be the most important?
I think wrestling because the ability to
dictate where the fight takes place and
by wrestling I include takedown defense,
which is obviously a wrestling skill,
but wrestling,
the ability to dictate where the
fight takes place is fucking critical.
And if you could take the guy down that
the having the ability to take a guy
down his giant,
you're on top of them,
you're smothering him,
he's got to carry your weight.
It's exhausting.
You're beating him up all he's down there.
It's just,
it's a giant factor,
you know,
all,
obviously every fight
starts standing up and,
but when a good striker is
finding a good wrestler,
they're fucking always
worried to let anything go.
As soon as they tee off on something,
Woo the doubles on them and
then they're on their ass.
So I think that a guy who has been
proven to be one of the most difficult
wrestlers to deal with,
to not have him fight in
the octagon is a tragedy.
It's fucking real bummer man.
Yeah,
it is.
And I wonder how many wrestlers out
there looking at in Ghana and going,
I wonder when it would happen
if you take that guy down.
Yeah,
I mean,
even me being in the same weight class,
I mean that's,
that's my,
my wife was asking me,
who would you be?
Um,
more terrified to fight before the fight,
you know,
with Alice,
how much should we reach?
62.
We can get you down to
a five gets you going.
The key.
Oh yeah.
But when Overeem and him were,
we're facing us,
she's like,
which one would you prefer to fight?
And I was like,
I think Negan,
I think Francis really well,
this was before he pays and,
uh,
Allister into orbit.
But,
uh,
I,
because he'd take him down
to come down and then,
uh,
and then it's your game.
Uh,
hopefully.
And so parents is so
seasoned and everything else,
uh,
and he does have some takedown defense
and he does have some submissions.
So I've just seen him
be more well rounded.
And uh,
so,
but that was before,
right before obviously.
Yeah.
I would've talked to you
before that and I said,
no,
because,
um,
my thought before the fight when I talked
to shop shop and I would talk on the
phone,
he said,
what do you think's going to happen?
I think,
I think he's,
I think Allister doesn't make
it out of the first round.
I think we went over all the
Times Alistair's been stopped.
That's a big factor.
It was a big factor.
I said no more than 10 times.
Yes.
More than 10 times in MMA,
I think it was,
what was it like 12 times 13 times in
MMA and then three or four times in
kickboxing as well.
What's that analogy?
Is there any truth to it?
It's almost like a peanut
butter jar or something.
The first time you open it,
you got to get out a towel and put
over it and tried to really hard to,
to open that lid and then after that it's
a little easier and then it's a little
easier until eventually you do it
enough and you can just spin it off.
Just flick it,
you know?
Well he's in the flick at stage,
but it doesn't matter.
That punch would have knocked him
out when he was 20 Oh yeah though,
talked to anyone else.
My hunch was in second tour,
Roy Nelson,
either either of those guys
and the way he threw it,
it was like a leg,
like from the thigh and then whipping
that arm with the whole body behind it.
Just full torque.
I mean it had everything.
It had all the power.
I was a little skeptical of the
[inaudible].
It was probably from listening to Brendon,
but talk about the punching power,
uh,
you know,
well,
who else has mark haunted it and has cro,
cop kicked it and everything else and
then all of a sudden once you see that
punch,
like,
uh,
he's,
he sealed the deal.
I'm sure she'll calm boy's hands and
it's like holding hands with a fucking
cinder block.
Let's see that again.
Boom.
See how he like comes up from the thigh
and the arm whips up look this way.
Oh my goodness.
And he's and his hand as he's punching,
he's moving in position
to punch a second time.
Then he Hammerfest some noise out bone.
Thank goodness he got in there.
He certainly,
I mean the referee got
in as quick as he could,
but he certainly could have
not hit him while he was down.
He was out cold.
We can say,
okay.
Knocked out with a bunch of the elbows.
Then they're like seven,
eight extra elbows at the end
before the ref stepped in,
in this past weekend.
Yeah.
Do you remember him talking to the
Gary Goodridge and weren't like elbows,
but like it was like,
ah,
man.
Probably just stop that early.
Pull up the card.
Sorry.
Try to figure out who it was.
Paul felt Paul Felder.
Yes.
Felder beat the shit out of him.
Yeah.
Um,
that was an interesting fight because
what played out is exactly what I thought.
I was like,
all Vera is really dangerous
with his grappling.
His grappling is phenomenal.
He is submitted,
I think he's tied with hoists.
Gracie for submitting
the most guys in the UFC,
which is how bad ass asses hoists
crazy all these years later as he has
throughout the record's awesome.
Pretty God damn significant.
Yeah.
But um,
he smashed him with that one shot and
then he had such great help with this man.
Yeah.
He tapped.
That's right.
That's what happened to and saw the tap.
Yeah.
And Felder just smashed him a Felder's
in an enormous 55 Felder walks around
somewhere in the 185 pound range.
And then GI,
it's down to 55.
Yeah,
he tapped,
but the referee didn't see it.
Two three.
And you know,
he can't let 'em up.
Five.
Oof.
Yikes.
She tapped a little harder than that.
Yeah,
you got to let don't,
I mean that's like a humble tap.
Like you got it.
You got to tap like,
okay,
we're done here.
Yeah.
You can't tap blood.
Didn't even realize it.
Tapped.
Can't be reluctant.
Can't have a reluctant tap.
It's got to be like,
but guys don't want to tap,
you know,
calm kind of tapping.
You know,
you've seen fives words guys
said they tapped but they didn't.
Yeah.
Yolanda thing,
she still says she didn't tap.
Yeah,
but she definitely did.
She probably doesn't realize should
tap cause she was in dreamland,
you know.
I mean she got hit so hard drip drop.
But guys have tapped said they didn't tap.
Remember Marilla Bustamante
and Matt Lindland.
That's what was going to say.
They restarted the fight.
Matt Lindland got caught in an arm bar,
clearly tapped and a big John McCarthy,
um,
separate was declaring
Bustamante the winner.
Lindland said I didn't tap,
I was moving around,
was moving around.
He was in town.
Okay.
And then most to Monte you can tell.
He's like,
what in the fuck are you serious?
And then they make them go back at it
again and then he catches them in a
guillotine the next round.
Yeah.
I mean I,
I started in 2005 or six fighting and
I remember a lot of wrestlers talking
about wrestler Trex as if someone,
if you go for the double leg and
he started getting a take down,
you know,
tap.
Here it is.
Watch.
That's,
well,
I don't know.
Hold on,
let me watch that again.
Let me watch that again.
Play it right there.
Yeah,
that looks,
so he's tapping,
but then he says there's not.
Hmm.
It seems like you wanted a tap,
but he didn't.
Hmm.
Let me see it again.
I'm less convinced now.
Watch this again.
Here it is.
He's got the arm turns him over.
Yeah,
that's a tap.
Yeah.
That's fucking top.
And then he said,
didn't,
I know a lot of wrestlers were
talking about if you know,
you get the guillotine,
try to see where the ref is and
then you can tap on the other side.
You remember jail did that.
Oh yeah,
it shell did that with
Polo field all in WEC.
Yeah,
that's right.
And then they fought again the second
time guys Celio didn't make weight and now
he catches him with the Guillotine.
And this is it right here.
Old School.
Carlson.
Gracie style son.
Yeah.
I mean most of Montana
was wizard back then.
A lot of people forgot how good
he was at the top of his game.
And he was one of the fun.
That's a tab right there.
And he was one of the fucking best.
Such a good Jujitsu guy.
I'm really good boxing too.
But uh,
Paul Fellow went crazy remembering it was,
who was kind of like the
second time they fought,
he missed weight.
So Sunnen should rightly by
all accounts really be the,
he should have been the
e c 185 pound champion.
But he never,
he never got that title because
Filo didn't make the weight.
And then they had some real weird
fight where like Filio was saying,
just do my,
my friend come to the ground with me.
He's like,
can't do that.
Sorry.
He's talking to him like,
you know,
you remember when,
but he could,
Paul had to like a kind of
a little bit of a breakdown,
right?
Yeah.
Kind of Mike Tyson Tattoo on his
face and he was acting real weird.
Appeared.
Yeah.
He was a monster at one point in time.
He was uh,
submitting everybody.
He was so good and he
submitted a bunch of people.
At least one or two
people in pride I believe.
Um,
but yeah,
he was a,
another guy.
He was a crossing Gracie guys.
Well,
right.
I believe so,
yeah.
World Class Jujitsu guy who's
just a little pit bull of a man.
Yeah.
Like the pre Paul Polaris.
What do you think about what
word rise in is doing now?
You know,
rising is trying to kind of
bring back the pride days.
I miss the pride days,
so yeah.
A lot.
So
I support it.
I hope they do it well and
doing a lot of freak shows too,
like they had was in rise and Gabby
Garcia versus some made the old lady,
the grandma on a couple.
Yeah.
There's one.
She literally fought a grandma,
not just joking around
like she was a grandmother.
Grandma with a bad knee.
Remember?
See,
like once it started it was
like they put her up to that.
Why she didn't want to be on that.
Why?
Why would they put her up there?
I have no clue.
Maybe they can't find
anyone to fight Gabby.
I'm sure they can't.
Yeah.
But uh,
it's almost like a,
I would rather not see
that fight happened though.
No,
Gabby Garcia is probably
225 pounds and jacked.
Yeah.
She would be in my training partner.
Yes.
Look legit.
Legitimately.
I'm six three,
two 62.
She'd be my train partner.
Crazy.
She'd be,
I think she's taller than you.
Oh,
she probably is.
She's a gorilla.
So big.
So finding a female competitor
to compete with her.
Good luck.
Yeah.
Well,
whenever they were always
talking about the rouse,
he could beat,
um,
guys in her division and
different stuff like that.
You would almost think that they have to
have no other options to where Gabby is
going to have to fight a guy someday.
I know,
right.
Maybe like a one 85 or
something like that.
But,
but yeah,
like good size of her.
Oh my goodness.
It's so insane.
And this is her versus a
little girl and kickboxing.
This is a kickboxing fight.
Oh my God.
She said,
oh what are those gloves?
Maybe a the smaller one.
Didn't want to fight her in MMA gloves
because they take too much of the beat
boxing gloves.
Don't think.
Yeah,
I think this is a kickboxing fight.
I think that's why they stopped
the fight after that takedown.
Okay.
Alright.
Cause they got back up to their feet.
It's like maybe it's
an MMA fighter though,
doing it.
Ooh,
she's getting battered.
I'm just getting hit by tree trunks.
But it's so crazy when she fought grandma,
that was a,
it was like,
I was sad for the woman that had to be,
had to go out there.
And this is in Brazil versus Megumi
Yabu she thought Japan brutal knockout.
Illegal soccer kick.
Okay.
I don't want to watch this.
Here it is.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Illegal soccer's Keck.
That's it.
That's good night.
Yeah.
When you're a hundred
pounds bigger than someone.
And please don't soccer kick
them when they're down illegally.
That's just seems like logical.
Adding insult to injury.
So what else is coming up next
that you're excited about is um,
Paul Daley Fighting Semtex um,
I mean Semtex fighting,
um,
uh,
Michael Denham page that they're,
they want to,
I know that some Texas going after that,
going after that one,
after that,
but I don't think it's finalized
cause Michael Page into the fight.
Does he want to have that fight?
I think he's a little more
on the fence about it.
I think daily is like campaigning
for at least the last I heard.
I love shit talking with a British accent.
Yeah.
It's one of my favorite things.
Anything with a British accent,
especially from daily,
you know,
like you look at him,
this muscular animal,
he's such a fucking psycho.
What a fucking lefthand that guy's,
Gosh,
when he stopped
Lorens Lark and I was like,
Whoa,
that's,
that's for real.
Yeah.
There'll be,
there'll be really exciting
to see if it happens.
Yeah.
Because even then on page
with that flying knee,
oh,
with the Cyborg one,
Jesus Christ.
I've never seen anything
like that in my life.
Yeah.
I think it's the right fight to do.
So hopefully pages
and I don't think he's,
I don't know,
maybe it's other other details they
need to work out to make it happen.
But um,
it seems like dailies the one
that's been campaigning for it.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Like have an page hasn't yet.
So,
yeah,
because after Roy McDonald beat daily,
daily,
it was immediately saying
he wanted to fight page.
Right.
It wasn't like saying like,
I didn't really want or if
I Rory a fuck this fight.
He's like immediately going after that.
He didn't want to rematch it.
Rory.
He was just Michael van page and
him have some serious bad blood.
Yeah.
Exciting.
Really exciting.
I don't know.
Here we go after boxing debut when
who's that's he had a boxing match.
Who's Paul daily.
That's funny.
Who the fuck is that guy?
Which is probably one of
the most brilliant lines.
No,
everyone else can copy.
What's amazing,
the timing,
the timing of that.
When Jeremy Stevens yelled that out,
um,
yeah.
Venom page looked amazing.
His boxing match.
It's like you're hearing all
this shit now about Connor Pob,
possibly fighting Paulie
Malignaggi and they patio,
right?
Huh?
No boxing match in a cage.
That was the,
the latest like a boxing
match in the octagon.
Listen,
the Dobie a m,
m,
e WME crew.
The people who own the UFC,
now they're w w I think they're willing
to put on whatever fights going to bring
in the most shekels.
You know?
That's what they got to do now.
And,
but now they got a star,
I think in Ghana knew
one or two more fights.
You're going to be looking
at Mike Tyson days.
That's what I think.
I think in Ghana was going to be like,
you're gonna Watch fights just to see
how long these motherfuckers can survive
against that guy.
That's what I think.
And I think that could be
their big breakout star Conner,
who knows if he's ever
going to fight again.
I mean,
we really don't know.
We haven't heard Conor saying,
you know,
this is my plan.
This is who I'm thinking about fighting.
This is what I want to fight.
He's been talking shit to Max Holloway.
He's been talking shit to Tony Ferguson,
but he's not sad like set it up.
So did you know what Francis was really
talking about whenever he was talking
about the slaves?
Yes.
That's so nuts.
Yeah,
we played that on the podcast.
We showed a lot of that stuff
that's going on in Libya.
They had open slave auctions and people
filmed it and put it on youtube in 2017
yeah,
I know multiple people from Uganda,
Rwanda and Congo that were um,
there were lured into some
of these countries like
there and they would go there
thinking that they were going to have
a job opportunity and that they'd be
working at this place or
that place or whatever.
And you start here and you work your way
up and automatically you're going to be
making more than you've
ever made in a year,
every week.
Um,
and so they go there thinking that
they're going be able to have a new job,
send back a bunch of
money to their family,
then all sudden they get there.
They take all their documents away
from them to where they can't travel.
They can't escape.
If they do,
they don't speak the language.
Um,
and then they throw him into someone's
house and they're literally their slave.
Um,
and they were lured there,
Nelson in your slave.
Um,
keeping them,
therefore they will
keep them there forever.
But then some of these
families that were able to,
some of these people that are able
to make contact with their families,
they have to fundraise and come up with
thousands and thousands of dollars.
I'm talking like an African family that
might make a dollar to a dollar 25 per
day is now having to come up with three,
four,
5,000,
$10,000 to try and grow.
I'm back to try to buy
them back out of it.
So,
um,
you know,
there's more slavery today than any
other time recorder industry in history.
Yeah.
So the lowest statistic is 27 million,
but I think it's over 30 million.
Just stop and think about it.
Most people in America,
if you talk to him about
slavery and they're like,
oh yeah,
that ended in 1865.
Nope.
Not only did it not end,
there's more today than ever,
but until we saw the Libya,
the youtube video where you see
the one guy saying he's a good,
he can lift heavy things.
He's a good digger.
And you're like,
what?
And they were selling
them for like 400 bucks.
600 bucks.
Yeah.
So the Loogootee pygmies actually,
so this is what the
documentary is really covering.
I cover a little bit of it in the book,
but we've actually seen 1500 people.
And that's what at the
comedy store tonight,
we'll play the short trailer for it and
it's going to talk about the slavery
that's in there.
Uh,
there's 400 to 600,000.
My booty pygmies in the
Congo and basically all of
them are enslaved currently
right now.
And so we've actually seen peaceful
negotiations of 1500 people transition out
of a life of slavery and
into a life of freedom.
And we're hoping that
we can replicate that.
And so how we're able to do it is
we're able to work with the local,
state and national government,
uh,
on documents.
And then also we're able to buy back
the land from the slave masters.
So they benefit financially by having
maybe more money than they've ever made
from their slaves.
Um,
and then,
uh,
we get water for both sides.
So the slave masters,
it's,
it's a different context for slavery.
There's a lot of places
like Libya or different,
um,
countries that they're really rich
and they have a bunch of slaves.
But in this context it's a,
a family owns a family in most cases.
Some,
some of them,
many families.
Uh,
but there I've attended the
funerals of the slave masters kids.
Um,
the slave master or the slave masters
kids are dying of dirty water because they
have zero access to it.
And so whenever you can bring in,
because they're making a dollar
a dollar 25 a day on the film,
there's going to be a beautiful
part on the documentary.
I don't want to ruin that part
or so many of the thunder,
but it's,
um,
man,
there was a slave master crying on camera
with us crying because of how much of
a benefit it's been.
The piece that's come from not having
the slaves that he inherited from his
father who inherited them
from his grandfather,
uh,
because it became a burden where
they're making a dollar dollar 25 a day,
they're spinning on average,
the average,
uh,
person and congressmen,
$185 a year on treatment
against waterborne disease.
So on medicine,
all stuff,
they're spending half of their
salary on waterborne disease.
They're losing their kids because of it.
And now there's making a dollar dollar
25 a day trying to take care of their own
family.
How are they supposed to take
care of their slave family?
And so they can give them just the scraps.
And so whenever we get
to come in there and say,
hey,
this land is rightfully
the [inaudible] pygmies,
they're the first citizens of,
of Congo.
They're the first people here.
They're the native Congolese.
Um,
they don't,
you think they deserve some land?
And so we kind of cast division
work together with them.
It's all inclusive to where they get to
share their concerns and questions and
they get to be part of that
and say we want this here.
And so then all of a
sudden once that happens,
we do the land purchases,
it's all legal.
And then,
um,
and then we bring in water for both
sides to where they both have clean water
access to that which changes everything.
Whenever the slave master's wife is on
average going 3.75 miles to go collect
water,
she can't do other things.
You imagine that you're,
you own slaves and you have to
walk three miles to get water.
We get water and,
or,
or you're a slave master.
And if you are fortunate enough that you,
your wife doesn't have to
go collect water all day,
one of your kids can't go to school
because they have to go collect water all
day.
And so in when those
Jerry cans or full 44 or,
sorry,
20 liters,
20 liters is 44 pounds when full.
And a lot of times you do it with too,
because if you're going to,
if you're not going to
carry it on your head,
and if you're going to
make the most of your time,
that 3.75 mile walk,
you're going to go at two Jerry cans on
that walk and then it will balance you
out,
almost like kettlebells.
Um,
and so you get to 44 pounds,
almost kettlebells,
but Jerry cans of water that's moving,
that's so hard to carry.
And he'd walk that back a hundred pounds,
88 pounds.
Yeah,
yeah.
88 pounds.
And so to be able to
alleviate some of them are,
are girls that are,
you know,
teenagers and stuff.
Um,
and trying to get an American
teenager to carry 88 pounds.
I mean,
I,
it hurts,
it hurts me going on.
Like literally,
I go on those.
All our team normally does the waterwalk
and every new village that we go to.
So probably 70 water walks.
No,
and there might be one
or two that we didn't do.
Um,
but the first 13 we did
when I was there and a man,
it's too to understand,
to put yourself literally in their shoes
and go on that long walk and to have
the sore neck from carrying it on your
head or to have just your shoulders dying
because you're walking
back with 88 pounds.
You're not doing,
I mean,
think about whenever we're
doing those kettlebell walks,
I mean,
how many feet are we going by?
Go miles that way on one of
those outdoors men's vests.
You know what those things are outdoors.
His pack it as a weight plate in back
of one of those posts for weight plates.
I slide on a 45 pound plate and I,
the hike the mountains with it,
just 45 pounds.
I weighed 200 pounds.
Why?
Why would 45 pounds be a lot?
It's a fucking lot,
man.
It's a lot.
So to think that these women are
carrying double that and they're walking
through the jungle.
Yeah,
it's fun man.
And,
and,
uh,
the,
it's not funny,
but I mean,
uh,
they,
they cracked up because
they're so used to,
uh,
to carrying this walk.
But I'm going down this,
this steep hill and it's on a little
foot trail and it's muddy because it had
been raining.
Um,
and so I'm having this thing on my head.
Oh,
I fall on my back in the water,
just soaks me because all the
water that we went and collected,
um,
no,
I mean half of it,
uh,
ended up on me and on the ground.
Did you go back and get more water?
No.
Wow.
No,
cause we were,
we were currently trying to drill the
new well and we were getting pretty close
to it.
Um,
and so,
but just slipped and fallen
while you're doing it,
losing your balance.
I sprained my knee one time on
one of the water walks because a,
you're carrying all this weight,
you step in a hole and then all of
a sudden you sprained your ankle,
sprain your knee,
different stuff like that.
Well,
listen,
Justin Wren,
you were doing the Lord's work.
You're doing amazing stuff,
man.
And I'm so happy that we can help and
I'm happy that we can help tonight.
If you were thinking
about coming to the show,
you're shit out of luck sold out.
It was sold out a long fucking time ago.
So,
uh,
tonight will be,
Tom Segura,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
Whitney Cummings,
Owen Smith,
Tom Papa.
Is that everybody and me there?
Is that it?
That's it.
That's the show tonight.
Nine 30 at the comedy store and all the
proceeds will be donated to fight for
the forgotten woo.
Woo,
whatever he said.
Yeah.
Thank you brother.
I appreciate you,
man.
Thanks Bro.